[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio e grazie per essere qui
perché senza di voi questa
manifestazione non avrebbe alcun senso
mi piace pensare che gli organizzatori
ne abbiano attribuito l'onore e il
privilegio di parlare per primo perché
condividono una mia impostazione di
fondo che tutto nasca dal pensiero da
come si formano i pensieri dal perché
alcuni pensieri si formino ed altri no
perché alcuni abortiscono o da altri non
vengano nemmeno concepiti in questo
senso quindi mi farebbe piacere mi
accontenterei del fatto che voi portate
a casa con voi solo il titolo dello
speciale quindi la metamorfosi del
pensiero mi rivolgo in particolare ai
professionisti ma intendo questa parola
in senso molto molto lato non solo i
liberi professionisti gli avvocati
ingegneri commercialisti medici ma anche
i manager gli insegnanti i dirigenti
chiunque abbia a che fare con delle
operazioni diciamo intellettuali ma poi
ovviamente va benissimo che si
preoccupano di questi tutti a cominciare
dai bambini
solo che con loro stasera non posso
parlare quindi mi rivolgo a quest'altro
tipo di platea dicevo è una questione di
metamorfosi di trasformazione alla quale
purtroppo nessuno ci ha avviato abituato
a noi professionisti hanno insegnato
sempre competenze tecniche io in tanti
anni e il diverse esperienze sono un po
deviato io e sono sicuramente curioso e
questo ha favorito questo mio percorso
di trasformazione io mi annoio quando ho
imparato a fare qualcosa devo farne
un'altra potrebbe essere un mio difetto
un vantaggio fate voi mi ha consentito
però oggi di riflettere
in tempo di cover e quindi recuperare un
po di tempo che gli altri magari non
hanno se sono occupati a fare quello che
fanno normalmente quindi la loro
attività professionale di base per
parlare quindi di trasformazione del
pensiero
vorrei iniziare con una domanda è
possibile secondo voi che noi prendiamo
circa 30.000 decisioni
ogni giorno io non sono forte in
matematica diversamente non avrei fatto
un avvocato però 30mila a decisioni
immaginiamo un secondo ciascuna sono 500
minuti sono più di otto ore
voi passate otto ore al giorno a
prendere decisioni ora questo potrebbe
cozzare con le vostre idee attuali e
semplifica il discorso diciamo che avete
due opzioni a disposizione o pensare che
io sia un cialtrone o che il numero me
lo sia inventato o che siano dei
cialtroni o che semplicemente sbaglino
gli studiosi che si occupano di processi
decisionali e che hanno tirato fuori
questa cifra sul corriere la sera
trovate che sembra che siano 35.800
delle quali dedicate solo le scelte del
cibo ecco non vi do subito la risposta
perché io non sto qui a dare risposte
non mi sono mai sentito alla torre di
nessuna verità assoluta
anche perché ho letto un sacco di libri
interessanti in cui si dice il contrario
che non sono importanti le risposte ma
sono importanti le domande
tant'è vero che il saggio dice che non
esistono risposte intelligenti a domande
stupide problema a scuola ci hanno
insegnato a farci le domande giuste o
volevano delle risposte magari già
preconfezionati
ora io vi lascio con la vostra opinione
e vi rassicura in questo senso non è
importante e anzi direi che anche
impossibile stabilire chi c'ha ragione
chi ci ha torto
dovremmo fare un salto in avanti non lo
faccio sono poi precipita ray sopra il
signor eco in prima fila ovviamente ma
un salto in avanti per dire ecco sta
abbracciando grazie mi astengo da farlo
il salto in avanti mentale di dire ma
dobbiamo veramente rimanere incassettati
in questa dicotomia torto o ragione si
le decisioni sono 30mila non so troppo e
buti sta dicendo un sacco di sciocchezze
oppure il mondo ci richiede
di andare avanti e pensare che possano
coesistere a proposito dello stesso
fenomeno dello stesso vento è della
stessa idea opinioni diametralmente
opposte
ecco questo l'università non ce l'ha mai
detto ci hanno costruito fin dalla
scuola almeno questa è la mia esperienza
a quello che vedo in tanti colleghi
tante piccole certezze la certezza
ovviamente fa sta tranquilla l'amigdala
è peccato che poi dopo con questo prende
delle decisioni qualche volta che non
sono proprio ponderate piene ma
soprattutto consapevoli
quindi vorrei iniziare con addio non è
sbagliata questa slide è veramente una
zecca questa è una zecca quella roba
terribile sanguisuga
non c'è nessun significato recondito
sulla funzione di questo animaletto il
mio è solo un artifizio diciamo un e
monica voi sentirete tante cose oggi
io ho cercato di fare il meglio per
limite delle mie possibilità per fare in
modo che questa serata sia utile per voi
e che quindi possiate portarvi dietro a
casa qualche cosa per portarvi dietro
qualcosa io devo essere in grado di
farvela comprendere ma la vostra memoria
deve essere in grado di trattenerla
ora siccome la memoria non funziona su
base volontaristica
quindi voi non potete stabilire che cosa
ricordare che cosa no perché sarebbe
lungo il discorso provate a fidarvi
cinque minuti di me e vi posso
assicurare che questa immagine che è
lievemente disturbante sta generando in
voi un minimo di emozione primaria che
normalmente è chiamata sorpresa
meraviglia è una delle sei emozioni
primarie senza una meraviglia non
staremo qui oggi a parlarne saremmo
morti tantissimi anni fa ora questo mi
serviva per creare un primo grappolo
diciamo un livello 1 e monica e poi
rendere la cosa un pochettino più
gestibile questo è un animaletto
immaginario che voi non potete conoscere
perché l'ho fatto appositamente per il
ted è la recca la re.ca è il mio marchio
di fabbrica e l'ho creata con il di ted
sono diventato sto diventando un piccolo
specialista in acronimi perché ho fatto
un corso di tecniche di memorizzazione
dei 54 ore e ho scoperto che funziona
meglio fatti
questa maniera speriamo che funzioni
anche con voi la re.ca è un acronimo
quindi significa che sono le iniziali di
alcune parole le cinque parole che io
vorrei che voi ricordate di questo
pomeriggio
r sta per qualche cosa no evidentemente
sta per qualche cosa e via dicendo
e resta per ruolo e sta per etica come è
stato detto nella presentazione è
diventato il mio debole e l'etica la
prima ci sta per comportamento la
seconda sta per complessità e la terza
asta per auto consapevolezza
ora il ruolo significa che
indipendentemente dalla funzione che noi
svolgiamo
se sei un magistrato un medico un notaio
ma anche ba benissimo il ciabattino
l'operatore ecologico puoi svolgere quel
ruolo in tanti modi diversi lo può fare
con poca passione ho pochissima passione
con nessuna passione con noi a lo può
fare in maniera brutale oa brutti va e
poi ovviamente diventa tutto più
faticoso è e quindi è importante capire
che avere autoconsapevolezza come
vedremo alla fine di come io interpreto
questo mio ruolo viene faccio l'avvocato
non è un punto arriva un punto d'inizio
ma che tutti fanno l'avvocato allo
stesso modo c'è qualcuno che lo fa
all'interno come vedremo di un certo
sistema di riferimento e qualcuno lo fa
con un altro sistema di riferimento
quindi ci sono tanti avvocati per essere
molto chiare per quanti sono gli
avvocati stessi è certo poi ci sono dei
cluster quindi potremmo trovare delle
persone che lo fanno in maniera molto
molto simile allora questo è un veloce
schematizzazione di quello che intendo
io per sistema di credenze qualcuno lo
chiama mai in sette in inglese sistema
di credenze io l'ho voluto semplificare
ne avete molte più di queste però per
farvi capire come io posso trasformare
l'ambiente in cui pensieri nascono
quella roba che sta qui dentro la
scatola cranica nel tempo io forse il
mezzo era nato con quel tipo di mindset
un pochettino cibata in effetti la
genetica quindi quello che ci hanno
trasferito i geni e i genitori ma quello
che ci hanno detto a scuola
le varie esperienze che facciamo quindi
io potrei pensare che il mondo è giusto
stabile e prevedibile che la realtà
oggettiva che l'uomo e razionale fatto
il liceo quindi ne parla ma vorremmo
coraggio incredibile
si canta perfetto tutto razionale oggi
abbiamo scoperto che siamo un pochettino
o tanto poco razionali bene male solo
assoluti che la memoria affidabile
ho dovuto legge e preferibile per capire
per sempre è bene non fidarsi dei
testimoni perché la memoria realtà non è
affidabile e quindi scendiamo da
quest'altra parte in cui basta metterci
un piccolo successo davanti e cambia
sostanzialmente il mondo cambia anche
l'effetto però che vi ingenera il
sistema di credenze perché qua la metti
dalla comincia ad andare un pochettino
in crisi c'è stata e voi a vivere in un
mondo che è ingiusto
una realtà che è soggettiva io sto
all'interno di un disco rosso forse voi
non lo vedete ma tutti sarebbero
disposti a dire il rosso nelson ci
mettiamo a utilizzare il colorimetro per
stabilire che punto di rosso è ma su
questo potremmo essere tutti d'accordo o
no è questo il problema è difficile
capire che c'è soccorse che diventano
molto più soggettive altre poco ma
l'oggettività pura dal mio punto di
vista ovviamente non esiste visto che
non dormo stamattina mi sono beccato nel
nnesimo ted in cui c'era un fisico che
diceva che noi non abbiamo un contatto
diretto con la realtà per il semplice
fatto che il cervello e privo di organi
di senso il cervello scambia tutte le
informazioni in mezzo a circuiti
elettrochimici è una scatola nera è
buono buio
quindi noi interpretiamo dei segnali e
poi che nel cervello gli davamo dei
significati ci serve il cervello per
comportarci diciamo da persone che hanno
delle relazioni piccolo ha dato
scientifico 98 e 6 per cento di dna in
comune che qui gli animaletti lino a
metà con la vespa ci abbiamo dna
con altri animaletti meno simpatici è
però con questi stiamo proprio vicini
vicini vicini vicini c'è qualche
differenza tra bonobo scimpanzé ma direi
che quell'atteggiamento lita
abbracciarsi e tipicamente umano è
tipicamente mammifero perché ci hanno
bisogno di relazione i mammiferi
serpenti s'abbracciano serpenti le
moschee non si abbracciano ecco per
capirci
ora il fatto che c'è una relazione
significa che quel gruppo deve averci
delle regole di funzionamento per ciò
che sembra mostrano ma vi sto dicendo
che anche se non c'è il codice civile
dei bonobo loro c'hanno delle regole e
ciano anche il modo per farlo rispettare
non c'hanno i tribunali il bonobo per
esempio fanno un'attività che piace a
tutti fanno tanto sesso non è una
battuta cioè è vero se voi guardate i
documentari il modo di composizione dei
litigi e di regolamentazione dei
rapporti inter sociali e su base
sessuale anche omosessuale
vivaddio lo fanno bene è un modo loro di
relazionarsi basta a mimare l'atto
sessuale perché tu stai in meta
comunicando la disponibilità e quindi se
quello è il capo tu stai dicendo che è
il riconosco che tu sei capo ovviamente
questa è tutta una sovrapposizione che
facevamo noi umani
però c'è gente che campa là in mezzo
alle scimmie per 40 anni e non so frans
de waal lago dal e colore la ste cose
la scienza dice che quando sono ripetute
in maniera sistematica forse ci hanno un
fondamento
vi sto dicendo quindi che per regolare
il comportamento non ci serve la
neocorteccia cioè quel terzo di cervello
in più che noi abbiamo rispetto a loro
l'essere umano cioè homo sapiens il
cervello più grosso di tutti gli altri
animali sia come volume che per qualità
e la neocorteccia e sviluppatissima solo
nell'essere umano
ciò non significa che si comportano
meglio è questo lo voglio sottolineare
qualcuno utilizza il termine volutamente
post moderno per dire che ormai il picco
di umanità l'abbiamo sorpassato dopo
ognuno posizione del piccone umanità
dove prevede dove vuole
c'è chi lo mette addirittura in homo
sapiens perché c'è stato un periodo in
cui sembra che noi spreca assimo in cui
massimo molto di meno si vivesse meglio
il meglio ovviamente anche questo è
e relativo evidentemente ora come
riusciamo a passare noi da questo schema
che è brutto perché vi sto dicendo che
siamo sostanzialmente un po animali no a
qualche cosa di veramente scusate
complicato come le relazioni umane e
l'ambiente moderno ora qui dobbiamo fare
una piccola puntualizzazione si tende a
pensare che complesso e complicato siano
sinonimi
non è assolutamente così non vorrei fare
il latinista però ve l'ho messo proprio
banale banane compli che con le pieghe
si replica e senza pieghe pay off e
rojas tiro l'euro le pieghe e non c'è
più la camicia spiegazzata se penso che
la complessità funziona allo stesso modo
penso che possa esistere un ferro da
stiro che riduce la complessità
impossibile la complessità non si riduce
ci vuole tempo anche a scegliere il
verbo da mettere prima della parola
complessità questo va in pari ovviamente
se cominci a capire che la complessità è
una materia che studia ci scrivono i
libri
oggi de toni a un'altra parte e parlava
de toni l'ex rettore di udine che parla
di complessità è una cosa stupenda ma
colpito tantissimo la cultura e forse
l'infrastruttura più importante di cui
questo benedetto paese c'è bisogno la
cultura un'infrastruttura non pensavamo
alla autostrade e treni e roba varia
perché lì sopra c'è un passante le cose
stupide la cultura riserva generare roba
intelligente complesso in effetti viene
più da greco che dal latino e il cum
stavolta è con blake tum che significa
intrecciato con i nodi
l'esempio migliore che ciò penso per
farvi capire la complessità nella rete
che può esistere una rete senza di noi
non sarebbe più una rete e come una
tessitura con l'ordito no è quella tra
attrezzo meno male sulla parola con il
verticale orizzontale ok
ecco se non ciò quei due aspetti non c'è
più un tessuto non c'è una rete allora
non la posso ridurre la rete ovviamente
si possono essere mai più grosso e più
piccola ma sembra rete rimane
ontologicamente e l'etimologia traina ci
dice anche un'altra cosa che significa
abbracciare in effetti noi non possiamo
ridurre la complessità pare non la
possiamo neanche
gestire ma la posso abbracciare
abbracciare per dire
intanto cazzarola quante grossa ok
perché un conto è fa un abbraccio
piccolino si abbracciate nelle fund e un
tronco insomma per fare un'idea di
quanti grossa questa complessità
questa immagine l'ho fatta volutamente
per darvi un'idea che significa
complessità in maniera trasportabile se
io mi chiedessi lo vorreste un mondo
senza terremoto o non era immagine
retorica potete rispondermi sì non lo
voglio nessuno lo vuole io sono
tormentato bis 97 e 2016 sono stato
fuori da casa un anno e mezzo
lo dico con molto rispetto però con
molto rispetto devo dire che bisogna
essere un pochettino realisti delle
volte il terremoto c'è un suo perché la
crosta terrestre sulla quale stiamo che
ci sembra tanto stabile né stabile per
niente si muove di continuo perché si
muove perché al centro della terra c'è
un nucleo solido di ferro e nichel a 5
mila gradi intorno c'è un strato di
ferro fluido che girando genera un campo
magnetico questo campo magnetico rende
sostanzialmente il centro la terra un
potentissimo magnete che crea la
magnetosfera una roba che noi non
vediamo se non quando andiamo a vedere
le foto dell'albero reali quella roba
verde fantastica quello è il bordeaux
più vicino la magnetosfera che fa quelle
immagini bellissime
ecco questo schermo invisibile d'aria i
raggi del sole e consente la vita di
essere possibile sulla terra
quindi per averci in un sistema senza
terremoti ci vorrebbe che ferrofluido
non ci sta quindi se non generiamo sotto
casa ci moriamo per le radiazioni
ionizzanti che vengo al sole è roba di
questo genere ok quindi bellissimo
questo affare che tiranno quello
evidentemente quello è poco
interpretabili cioè io devo dire a fare
lì cammina con numeri quindi quello che
sta dicendo che sto per morire cioè come
speaker ovviamente ora il vila e vi devo
lasciare quindi con un messaggio che
ieri abbiamo fatto il problema hanno
detto metti c'è quella davanti che è
fondamentale non è la consapevolezza che
ci interessa ma l'auto consapevolezza
cioè io dovrei cercate capi che succede
dentro la mia capoccia non so quanti di
voi erano arrivati mentre scorrevano i
video iniziale ma c'era un video
all'inizio in cui parlava di quello che
era la mia conclusione cioè i by us ski
tobias a una parola bruttissima la
possiamo tradurre in italiano con
euristica o scorciatoia cognitiva
quando io ho capito che sistema questa
roba
grado su entrato in crisi perché dove
metto la barra del libero arbitrio a
questo punto
voi sapete quanti baia se ci avete
dentro al cervello questa sì che mo
retorico come domanda perché se non
leggi sta roba è difficile pare che
siano più di 300 censo 23 che utilizzate
p continuo la disponibilità la
rappresentatività e l'ancoraggio fanno
parte della nostra vita comune
il problema è che se tu non lo sai pensi
che è scisso tuo se comprare che la
marca di acqua minerale tra le 250 che
ci stanno
oppure l'hai comprata perché c'era il t
al tizio tale che faceva il testimonial
perché la etichetta era di un certo
colore o perché l'acqua stessa stava in
un certo scaffale voce aveva un certo
prezzo attenzione gli economisti
neoclassici prima che si scoprisse sta
roba negli ultimi 40 50 anni pensavano
che donava comprare l'acqua minerale
effettivamente in base al prezzo e se
fosse così tutti quelli che fanno
marketing e pubblicità tutti disoccupati
ovviamente no ecco quindi la mia
trasformazione di pensiero è che se
vogliamo innalzare la qualità delle
nostre decisioni
dobbiamo mettere un pochettino più da
parte la tutta la conoscenza tecnica che
ci hanno dato e che era costruire viene
in mente sul mondo che non c'è più del
passato
non sto rinnovando le tradizioni sono a
mia madre mi frustrerebbe ovviamente ma
visto il genio che queste tradizione ma
hanno in qualche modo modernizzati e poi
ho visto quel video stupendo del sul
bhutan prima messo innamorato cioè se po
fa sta roba è
e noi abbiamo il pensiero limitante
quindi vi sto invitando allevare questo
velo di inconsapevolezza e andare verso
l'auto consapevolezza
grazie mille
[Applauso]